[Music]
perfectly they were may know me
yesterday for we're never as a mother I
don't know I don't like Aliana or even
doubt even nuns other wonders kind of in
the beta me nourishment I know my
stomach I read one other before I wrote
it already
[Music]
Nina is a oldest-known woman practicing
Kalaripayattu an ancient south indian
martial art the art of flurry is
practiced with the use of one's bare
hands
sticks and heavy swords and shields that
yani on again nothing in Leon Matheny
was another body another I'm mom my
mother can only get I know that she's
like a mother too friable to happen if I
did I cut it mud yet and then take on a
southern that's a little bigger than um
okay really anybody child but it's a
mono the idea in little man serum I'm
sorry Jeremiah
okay our career Alec ID but it's a lot
about the module one dollar and I don't
know anybody colonel particle you get a
solid water remember participa member
say what I am raise never increase right
now
star accommodation over the over guitar
alone they recommended
[Music]
we are the only memory in all the
Himalayas dream deadly my Terada these
nuns can even break bricks with her
hands and the purpose behind this
practice is sacred
this is it like long box I make it for
to Basel and I am very proud of my
practice my name is I'm a young gent
Camus Sigma means fearless I'm a
component of the Troopa order the Drupa
order is a branch of Buddhism that has
been around for thousands of years but
in 2008 the nunnery based in Katmandu
Nepal started to learn kung-fu as part
of their spiritual practice a generate
nuns I heard eat reporter no Jiang Mei
wanted to be a nun since she was a
little girl I'm ten years old when I
became a man I considered all the nuns
like my family no other nunnery in Nepal
does kung fu training and Jigme and her
sisters go the extra mile to master this
art form the true power is not for lazy
people we wake up at 3 a.m. we meditate
with bicycle we train for the two hours
they run in climb up stairs to
strengthen their bodies and they use
sticks and fans to enhance their
coordination the hard work is rewarding
and the purpose of training these nuns
to fight all comes back to the
philosophies of peace and equality over
trained us to focus outline for
meditation
the nuns also take these philosophies
and apply them to disadvantaged
communities in Nepal in 2015 when a
devastating earthquake hit Katmandu the
nuns knew this was their call to action
when the earthquake hit all confer
training help us to brave and strong we
went to many villages that many NGOs and
government thought that it's too
dangerous
we bought mini supplies we survived the
lines
Evelynn gist and out quick the nuns also
biked 14,000 miles throughout Nepal to
protest against the human trafficking of
women and girls we talk a lot equality
and safety we wanted to show everyone
that noise can ride bicycle and the
girls can do anything I learned I can do
anything for mankind confu has trained
me to be confident strong and happy the
teachings helped me put my compassion
into action helping others is my
religion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
de belem ' what you know who but since
our three martinis thought up since the
user weight analogy where he was husband
continued Atossa webathon da da da daaaa
Suzanne modernisme
kinesiology major Susanna was remain
hungry for ties hungry vegetable hash is
a shearing assemblies so to : family
during the obey our passage in Via dei
[Music]
hiring a Jota regimen where possible
hospital's Ohio Bui build collagen
ippatsu ki tamanna Saguna you got a
musical challenge I travel generally
Trini gratata general hydrophilicity
what is hi
[Music]
bori billion fans today are launching
Tsubasa's high state outside air is
baggage also bush was hung juries have
versus yours or tourism
she was hung juries have worked as a
surety down chang-geun will be oh yeah
you understand any history sure she made
Eng Bernie and she [ __ ] about as Senator
Kennedy watchers would yo honey singh ji
e Bhuvan yung semore photo and today
some adrenaline tomatoes for Marvin J
[Music]
I'm good at PR Enda goes hungry with
high years own or just wash machine
Japan's amazing Hasani decision then for
all cheering for you learn how to design
company ha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um champion sera sera
sorry um dr. Neeraj is our true love
what is a cotton you gonna be teacher
clear lot huh
bottom click forward to Italy so very
true nature gentleman Cipolla
to how from the humor
[Music]
washing Li Jalili and we're watching
enter serious a Chinese kung-fu dates
back thousands of years among the
hundreds of fighting styles is an
obscure technique called body shrinking
practitioners trained for years to
dislocate their joints for increased
flexibility the style was almost lost to
time and Lee is one of the aren't slaps
remaining masters right here so a
California was shocked how a human thumb
drill war for independence and hardware
to be well look I really am in charge
intuition really turn your face
Humphreys under tyranny infer from
Toronto the new P column requires tau
our daily aqua
mahjong player me Audrina
Miyoko Selena to send our young children
Italian polio Torah portions initial
idea CS Florida will assume the role of
peace under Sharia joyfully Aurora
conditioning giver in the trunk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
TECA or no Tom be built on the chin
gotcha hajikko da-da-dum tamale Odawa
conceal corydoras or hatchet immortal
since I got an iconic American guerrilla
[Music]
te amo tanto hamnida san jinan ingen
menagerie sofa Torico Joe Giudice tikona
Yangon Gennaro TM trajectory Sudha
Hector no nazo
Brito disorder a cure Tom de Ajo
technician bandagi no sir - heroin on
tan puranam Kron emergent and erase me
that akira-san gusta como de esta su
moto Italian John Cougar Stephenson
baroque women Sue Traylor a rock saga
gentlemen okusawa station a hundred
emoji Maggie Chen kegui East London guru
nanaka Tamara go cheap on Mistral código
de pandas 400 Oh Becky go Papa Hamels Oh
dr. boham of the Human Services chief
general she not grant goes for academia
the mikoshi onozonozo a determiner
Sunday Bangor piratin aqua park or
dessert party Azuga higher colleague is
only one quran go or Shipton us where
amalgam
[Music]
blitter Takasugi Babita melody whoa
don't I get our children go to challenge
my guillotine Mira
I am stronger kendama melancholic anyway
she yogamaya Sri Lanka volunteer tempo
maharaja tunga door or to obtain bhakti
means higher material dr. Allen dr.
around a year kokujo tengen about to get
our kiss me
[Music]